bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo une vidéo un petit peu
particulière puisque c'est la 13e sur la
chaîne et je me suis dit que le numéro
13 ça portait malheur donc j'allais vous
faire un truc un petit peu différent et
donc cette vidéo va être un hors série
où je vais faire un petit bilan de ce
qui s'est passé sur la chaîne pendant
les six derniers mois
et puis vous parlez aussi un petit peu
de l'avenir de la chaîne
la chaîne existe depuis six mois
maintenant et je suis vraiment très
content de ce qui s'est passé puisque
alors à l'heure où je tourne la vidéo il
ya à peu près 7000 abonnés alors
j'espère que d'ici à ce que la vidéo
sortira brook ou plus et il faut savoir
que chaque fois que l'un de vous sa
bonne je reçois un petit mail et donc ça
fait six mois qu'aujourd'hui soit
plusieurs dizaines de mails par jour
comme le dira claude et dans sa mode et
à chaque fois ça me fait l'effet d'un
espèce de petits câlins virtuels donc
merci à tous ceux qui se sont abonnés
merci surtout à ceux qui ont partagé les
vidéos parce qu'on vous lis souvent mais
c'est le principal moyen qu'on a de
faire connaître notre travail donc
n'hésitez pas à partager des vidéos
je vais évidemment continuer à faire des
vidéos j'ai juste faire une petite pause
pendant l'été parce que déjà j'imagine
que vous avez peut-être autre chose à
faire que regarder des vidéos et puis
moi aussi je veux avoir autre chose à
faire parce qu'en fait je vais déménager
alors ça se voit pas forcément dans les
vidéos mais j'habitais à boston aux
états unis
et cet été je vais rentrer en france à
paris précisément donc bah déjà le décor
va changer
et puis évidemment pour moi ça va être
aussi peut-être l'occasion de me
rapprocher un petit peu plus de la
communauté des vidéastes culturelles et
notamment des vies date scientifique
donc j'espère que c'est quelque chose
qui pourra aussi se voir dans
l'évolution de la chaîne alors parmi les
nouveautés dont je voulais vous parler
comme pas mal de youtube heures j'ai
décidé de créer une page sur tipi alors
pour ceux qui connaissent pas tipi en
fait c'est un site qui permet de faire
du financement participatif et ça
fonctionne un peu selon le principe du
mécénat si vous voulez ou du micro au
mécénat
c'est à dire que vous avez la
possibilité de faire un don - micro dons
pour soutenir des créateurs et notamment
des vidéastes
j'ai donc créé une page sur type il
mettra le lien je sais pas dans la
description dans la vidéo ci gérer
et ça permet à ceux d'entre vous qui le
souhaitent de soutenir financièrement la
chaîne en faisant un petit don ça peut
être un don complètement symbolique un
même 1 euro vous savez c'est déjà
beaucoup
ma principale idée en faisant ça c'est
avant tout d'essayer d'améliorer mon
matos en fait il faut savoir que quand
j'ai commencé cette chaîne
j'ai démarré un peu avec ce que j'avais
sous la main et notamment je filme avec
un appareil photo que j'aime beaucoup
pour faire des photos mais qui est pas
du tout adapté pour faire des vidéos bon
on peut filmer déjà que pendant 10
minutes d'affilée ce qui est quand même
un petit peu pénible parce que vous
doutez que tourner une vidéo ça prend un
petit peu plus que 10 minutes
notamment il n'y a qu'une seule focale
fixe que je peux pas changer donc j'ai
absolument aucune possibilité de faire
des zooms c'est ça ou rien j'ai aussi
quelques petits problèmes de fréquence
d'image que certains résidants des
vidéos
voilà ça j'aimerais vraiment l'améliorer
autre exemple un jeu tourné avec un
micro qui est sympa qui est pas cher
mais qu'à une légère tendance à
grésiller quand on bouge les câbles et
donc je me retrouve régulièrement au
montage à essayer d'effacer des bruits
grésillement parasites
donc je perds pas mal de temps et
d'énergie en fait à cause du fait que
j'ai pas un matériel très très adapté et
je préférais dépenser ce temps et cette
énergie pour écrire des nouvelles vidéos
ou alors améliorer mes illustrations des
animations etc
voilà donc si vous voulez aider la
chaîne me soutenir financièrement me
permettent d'acheter du meilleur
matériel et donc de continuer à faire
des vidéos et à les faire régulièrement
vous avez la possibilité de me soutenir
sur ma page tipi nous
le lien quelque part dans la description
ou dans la vidéo mais autre chose dont
je voulais vous parler c'est que même si
j'ai pas un nombre démentiel d'abonnés
je me suis dit que c'était un petit peu
dommage de ne pas en faire profiter les
autres et donc je vais essayer de vous
parler de quelques chaînes scientifique
que j'aime bien et dont je pense qu'elle
pourrait avoir beaucoup plus à donner
la première c'est cette chaîne qui
s'appelle chou romanesco vache qui rit
et intégrale curviligne oui c'est son
prénom donc en fait il faut savoir que
au départ show romanesco c'est tout
simplement le meilleur blog francophone
de vulgarisation des mathématiques je
préférais et ça fait maintenant quelques
mois que l'auteur du blog algie a décidé
aussi de faire des vidéos et donc il a
fait déjà peut-être une petite dizaine
de vidéos et je vous recommande vraiment
d'aller les voir elles sont absents
vraiment bien et notamment la dernière
vidéo qu'il a fait sur les fractales
elle est franchement renversant
donc allez-y et abonnez-vous à choux
romanesco une deuxième chaîne dont je
voudrais faire la pub c'est une chaîne
qui s'appelle motorsport gigan de raptor
alors comme son nom l'indiqué en fait la
chaîne parle essentiellement d'un côté
de voitures de course et de l'autre côté
de paléontologie bon et l'animateur de
la chaîne qui s'appelle aurélien je
crois qu'il ya quelque chose comme 13
ans et il fait un boulot absolument
incroyable il explique notamment des tas
de choses sur la théorie de l'évolution
qui montre que il a mieux compris la
théorie d'évolution que la plupart
d'entre nous est vraiment à chaque fois
je suis bluffé par ce qu'il fait donc je
vous invite à aller voir cette vidéo est
à vous abonner à cette chaîne voilà je
voulais aussi répondre à deux questions
qu'on me
très régulièrement dans les commentaires
la première c'est qu'on me demande
quelles études j'ai fait alors j'ai fait
une thèse en physique théorique et mon
sujet de thèse c'était je cite modèle de
mousse de spin pour la gravité quantique
en trois dimensions alors qu'est ce que
c'est en gros j'ai travaillé dans un
domaine qui cherche à unifier la
mécanique quantique et la relativité
générale et qui s'appelle la gravité
quantique à boucles
donc j'ai eu l'occasion de faire
allusion dans certaines vidéos et donc
vous comprenez pourquoi je suis assez
porté sur le question de relativité
générale mécanique quantique l'univers
tout ça est donc bah faut vous attendre
à ce que à l'avenir je traite encore ces
sujets là sur la chaîne l'autre question
qu'on me pose souvent parce que nous ne
remarquons fait un commentaire c'est
pour me dire que je devrais contacter
bruce de la chaîne y penser pour lui
parler de ma chaîne alors en fait
rassurez-vous bruce connaît déjà à ma
chaîne en fait il faut savoir que bruce
et un lecteur de mon blog avant d'avoir
une chaîne ça fait maintenant cinq ans
que j'ai un blog de vulgarisation
scientifique qui s'appelle aussi sur ces
90 et donc bruce de temps en temps lille
blog et qu'on a déjà eu l'occasion de
ses crayons s'est jamais rencontré
physiquement mais on a déjà échangé sur
des sujets que je traitais traitait
dernier petit coup de pub pour finir
sachez que je fais partie du portail qui
s'appelle vidéo science qui est hébergé
par le café des sciences et les vidéos
science c'est en quelque sorte un
annuaire qui regroupe quasiment toutes
les chaînes youtube de vulgarisation
scientifique
donc si vous connaissez pas la vidéo
science je vous invite à aller voir et
je suis sûr que vous allez découvrir
plein de chaînes scientifique que vous
connaissez pas forcément et dont
j'espère qu'elle vous plaira
voilà donc c'est tout pour ce premier
hors-série jeu sortirait probablement
une dernière vidéo d'ici deux semaines
avant l'été et puis après on se
retrouvera en septembre dans un nouveau
décor avec des nouvelles des vidéos et
d'ici là je vous dis à bientôt